In this section, we will go over a simple use case scenario using the Propagate changes
from Scene to DNA script to make some minor modeling adjustments to the neutral head mesh
using the joints and skin clusters.
This approach might be useful if, for instance, you need to reposition the joints around the
neck region to fit the head to a different body, or you simply want to make some minor
modeling changes.
We will assemble the scene for this specific scenario using the DNA viewer run in Maya
script.
Then, we will save the current positions of the vertex and joints.
We will make a simple modeling adjustment using the joints and skin clusters, and then
save those changes to the DNA file.
So let's return to Maya and go through the steps.
Back inside of Maya, we will first assemble the scene using the DNA viewer run in Maya
script.
I will switch to the Python window with the DNA viewer run in Maya script, and then select
everything and execute it.
In the DNA viewer window, assign the path to the DNA file.
In the DNA files folder, I will select the DNA file named Elina, and then load the DNA.
For this example, I want to assemble all of the LODs and their contents, so I will click
on Select All Meshes.
In the build options for this workflow, we can load the joints, the blend shapes, and
the skin clusters.
And now, I will select Process.
This will create a new scene, so I will discard any changes.
And this may take a moment.
Now that the scene has been assembled, I will minimize this window and go to the top view.
I'm going to go down here to the bottom right, and will hide everything except LOD 0 for
now.
In the script editor, I will switch over to the Python window with the Propagate Changes
script to save the current affairs.
In the Outliner, select the head group.
And then in the script editor, I will scroll past all this code and select everything all
the way to the end of step 3.
With this selected, I'm going to execute this.
As a best practice, save this Maya scene.
Now let's do a quick review of these steps before we move on.
We begin the workflow of making adjustments using the joints and skin clusters by first
assembling the scene using the DNA viewer run in Maya script.
Load the DNA file located in the DNA files folder.
We will want all the LODs and their contents, so choose Select All Meshes.
In the Build Options, load the joints, blend shapes, and skin clusters, and then select
Process.
This will assemble a new Maya scene.
Next, we will want to save the current affairs.
For this step, we want to save the current vertex and joint positions.
To do this, in the script editor, with the Python tab that has the entire script pasted
in there, select the head group in the Outliner, and then run the entire script up to the end
of step 3, which reads Loaded Data, End of Third Step.
As a best practice, save this Maya scene.
Now let's return to Maya and continue with the steps.
Back inside of Maya, with everything saved, we can now make some modeling changes using
the joints and skin clusters.
Something to note is that if you have loaded the DNA file with RigLogic enabled, you will
need to break the connections before you make any changes using the joints and skin clusters.
Otherwise, you can go directly into making simple modeling changes.
If RigLogic is enabled, to break the connections, select Spine 4, then go to Select, and select
Hierarchy.
Go over here to the Transforms, select All the Transforms, and right-click and select
Break Connections.
We do not need to do this, but I am mentioning this in the event you have assembled the full
Rig.
Now what's great about this particular workflow is that by moving the joints and skin clusters,
those changes will influence the other LODs.
I will switch this to Translate.
And over here on the head, I'm going to select this group over here on the nose and adjust
the nostril area.
I will repeat this for the other side.
Now this can be especially helpful if perhaps we need to fit the head to a custom body.
We can move the joints in order to align them with the custom metahuman body skeleton.
Another benefit is that these changes are passed down to the lower LODs.
In the Display panel, if I toggle through the lower LODs, the changes that were made
to LOD 0 will be visible for all of these without having to wrap anything.
Now let's do a quick review of what we just covered before we move on.
To make modeling changes using the joints and skin clusters, if RigLogic is enabled
and a full Rig has been assembled, first break the connections, otherwise you can go directly
into making modeling changes.
To break the connections, select Spine 4, go to Select and select Hierarchy.
Select all the transforms, right click and select Break Connections.
You can then use the joints and skin clusters to make modeling changes.
The benefits of this workflow is that changes to the joints influence all the LODs so that
there is no need to wrap LODs.
This can also be helpful if you need to align the head skeleton with the custom metahuman
body skeleton.
Once you are finished making adjustments, the next step is to save these changes to
the DNA.
So let's return to Maya and continue.
Back inside of Maya, we are finished making adjustments and now want to save these changes
to the DNA file.
To do this, select the head group, then in the script editor, go down here and select
Step 5 and execute this.
This will save the changes to the DNA file and a new DNA file will be added to the output
folder that the script creates.
A new Maya scene will be assembled so that we can inspect the results.
In this new Maya scene, I will go to the top view.
We can see that the changes we made to the clavicle have been saved and the changes to
the nose region are present.
And these changes have also been applied to the lower LODs.
And this is how we can use the Propagate Changes script to make changes using the joints and
skin clusters.
Now let's do a quick review of the steps we just covered before moving on.
Once finished making changes using the joints and skin clusters to save the new vertex and
joint positions, and update the DNA, select the head group and then run the script from
the fifth step that reads Propagate Changes to DNA.
These changes will be saved to a new DNA file in the output folder and a new Maya scene
will be assembled so that we can view the updated DNA.
In the next section, we will go over how we can export the head LODs of our modified
DNA with the Export FBX script from the Examples folder.